What comes to mind when you think of hypnosis? A swinging pocket watch? A hapless volunteer on a stage clucking like a chicken? Hypnosis in many people's minds is the province of charlatans and showmen. But this image of hypnosis is outdated and misleading. Over the past several decades, psychologists and other researchers have learned more about how hypnosis actually works, and they found evidence that it can be useful in treating pain, anxiety. anxiety and a range of other physical and mental health problems.
当你听到催眠时，你会想到什么？一个摇晃的怀表？舞台上咯咯叫得像鸡一样的倒霉志愿者？在许多人眼中，催眠是江湖郎中和卖艺人的把戏。但这种催眠的形象已经过时且具有误导性。在过去几十年里，心理学家和其他研究人员对催眠的实际运作机制有了更多了解，并且他们发现证据表明，它在治疗疼痛、焦虑以及一系列其他身心健康问题方面非常有用。
So what exactly is happening in people's bodies and brains when they're hypnotized? What's the difference between stage tricks and hypnotherapy used in pain management? Can anyone be hypnotized? What kinds of physical and mental health issues can hypnosis address? And if you want to see whether hypnosis can help you, how can you find a qualified practitioner whom you can trust. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. David Patterson, a professor of medicine and psychology
那么，当人们被催眠时，他们的身体和大脑究竟发生了什么？舞台戏法与用于疼痛管理的催眠疗法之间有什么区别？任何人都能被催眠吗？催眠可以解决哪些身心健康问题？如果你想看看催眠是否能帮到你，又该如何找到你可以信赖的合格执业医师？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，专门探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是大卫·帕特森博士，他是医学和心理学教授
at the University of Washington School of Medicine. Dr. Patterson specializes in pain, control, and recovery from physical trauma, burn injuries, and other forms of disabilities. He is also internationally known for his work in clinical hypnosis. Over the past several decades, he has led many National Institutes of Health-funded studies on Hypnosis for Pain Management, has published more than 100 articles on hypnosis in peer-reviewed journals, and has written a book for APA on hypnosis for pain control. Dr. Patterson, thank you for joining me today.
就职于华盛顿大学医学院。帕特森博士专门研究疼痛控制，以及从身体创伤、烧伤和其他形式的残疾中恢复。他也在临床催眠领域享有国际声誉。在过去的几十年里，他领导了许多由美国国立卫生研究院资助的关于疼痛管理催眠的研究，在同行评审期刊上发表了100多篇关于催眠的文章，并为美国心理学协会撰写了一本关于疼痛控制催眠的书。帕特森博士，非常感谢您今天能来到节目中。
Thank you, Kim. It's an honor to be here, and I wanted to thank you. It's my understanding that you've started this podcast. And it's, you know, I've listened to several of them. And it's a wonderful way to take popular topics and really provide a scientific basis that psychology can provide. So my compliments an appreciation to you. Well, thank you.
谢谢你，金。很荣幸能来到这里，我也想谢谢你。据我所知，你创办了这个播客。而且，你知道的，我听过其中的好几集。这是一种将大众话题与心理学能够提供的科学基础完美结合的绝佳方式。所以向你致以敬意和赞赏。好的，谢谢。
And I think we're going to do that today because we will demystify hypnosis, I hope, and explain it scientifically. So let's start with that image problem I alluded to in the introduction. what is the difference between the hypnosis that you and other psychologists practice and the kind of stage tricks that may come to mind when some people think about hypnosis? I'll start with stage hypnosis and that, you know, most people have a concept of hypnosis based on what they've seen on TV. And interesting little trick about stage hypnosis. If you watch a lot of them work, what they would do is get 20 volunteers up on stage. they'll give them a suggestion and they'll see that maybe five of them will really follow the
我想我们今天就是要这样做，因为我希望我们能揭开催眠的神秘面纱，并从科学角度解释它。让我们从我在引言中提到的那个形象问题开始。你和其他心理学家所实践的催眠，与有些人想到催眠时脑海中浮现的舞台戏法有什么区别？我先从舞台催眠说起，你知道的，大多数人对催眠的概念都是基于他们在电视上看到的内容。关于舞台催眠有一个有趣的小把戏。如果你看很多这类表演，你会发现他们通常会让20名志愿者上台。他们会给这些人一个暗示，然后你会发现其中大概有5个人真的会深深地接受这个
suggestion deeply like falling asleep on your neighbor's shoulder or whatever so they send the rest of the people back to their seats and they work with those highly hypnotizable people and they make them do ridiculous things so so what one thing is that they select for hypnotizability and the other is we're at the international a meeting for international for society for clinical experimental hypnosis. And we had some stage hypnotists from Las Vegas talk to us. And basically what they emphasized is people want to be part of the act.
暗示，比如靠在邻居肩膀上睡着之类的，于是他们把剩下的人送回座位，只和那些高度易被催眠的人合作，让他们做出荒谬的事情。所以一方面，他们是挑选易被催眠的人；另一方面，我们现在正参加国际实验与临床催眠学会的会议。我们有一些来自拉斯维加斯的舞台催眠师和我们交流。基本上，他们强调的是人们想要成为表演的一部分。
And so they're not, the hypnotists are not sure whether they're hypnotized or not, but it becomes kind of all part of the show. Okay. So that's stage hypnosis. What we found as psychologists is, first of all, that it's far more than a placebo and that it can be a very powerful treatment to,
因此，他们并不确定人们是否真的被催眠了，但这成了整场演出的一部分。好的，这就是舞台催眠。作为心理学家，我们发现的第一点是，它远不止是安慰剂，它可以是一种非常强大的治疗方法，可以用来治疗
you know, you mentioned pain and anxiety, irritable bowel syndrome is another one. But the way we do it is, I mean, we're very often looking at what's happening in the brain while we're studying people and we're also using outcome measures. And the final thing I mentioned, and I think it's very important is that hypnosis is known to increase the effect size of psychotherapy
你提到的疼痛和焦虑，肠易激综合征是另一个例子。但我们这样做的方式是，在研究人们的过程中，我们经常观察他们大脑中发生的事情，我们还会使用结果测量指标。最后我要提到的一点，我认为非常重要，那就是众所周知，催眠可以提高心理治疗的效应量
by a large amount. So what is happening in people's brains and bodies when they're hypnotized? Like if you put somebody in an fMRI when they're hypnotized, how will their brains behave in a different way? One of the best people I've ever heard talk about this is named Pierre Rainville, and he's up in Montreal. And I asked him once, is there a different brain state with hypnosis? And he goes,
幅度相当大。那么，当人们被催眠时，他们的大脑和身体究竟发生了什么？例如，如果你把某人放进核磁共振仪里进行催眠，他们的大脑会表现出什么不同的方式？我听过对此进行讲解的最佳人选之一叫皮埃尔·兰维尔，他在蒙特利尔。我曾经问过他，催眠时是否存在不同的大脑状态？他说，
you're asking the wrong question because there's a series of brain changes that happen. So you initially see activity in a left frontal lobe as people attend to whatever suggestions are. This is where the swinging watch comes in. That's just a way to capture people's attention. But then what happens is, is it looks like the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex shuts down.
你问错问题了，因为会发生一系列的大脑变化。当你专注于任何暗示时，你最初会看到左额叶的活动。这就是摇晃的怀表发挥作用的地方。那只是吸引人们注意力的一种方法。但接下来发生的是，背外侧前额叶皮层似乎关闭了。
So the rear of the frontal cortex disengages. And then the ACC, which is the part of our brain that motivates us, engages at the same time. So basically what happens is that people give up, judging what's happening to them or caring what's happening, and they just become very open to suggestion. And then finally, as people get suggestions, you see different parts of the brain activated,
因此，额叶皮层的后部解除激活。与此同时，作为我们大脑中激励我们行动的部分，前扣带回皮层被激活了。所以基本上发生的情况是，人们放弃了对正在发生的事情的判断或关心，变得非常容易接受暗示。最后，随着人们接受暗示，你会看到大脑的不同部分被激活，
and very often you see a transfer of activity to the non-dominant hemisphere. So it's really those three phenomenon, increased attention, dampening of the prefrontal cortex, and then engagements in various areas of the brain, depending on the suggestion. And it's not asleep. I mean, people are conscious, right?
而且你经常会看到活动转移到非优势半球。所以实际上是这三种现象：注意力增加、前额叶皮层减弱，然后根据暗示激活大脑的不同区域。它不是睡眠。我的意思是，人们是有意识的，对吗？
They know what's happening around them when they're in this state. Is that correct? Yes and no. First of all, we like to dispel myths of hypnosis. A lot of people are afraid they'll fall asleep with hypnosis, and that almost never happens because in some cultures, that's a form of embarrassment. And for the most part, people are aware of what's going on, but with some of the deep complex hypnosis that we use in psychotherapy, very often it's like saying your brain is shut off
当他们处于这种状态时，他们知道周围发生了什么吗？对还是不对？两方面都有。首先，我们要消除对催眠的迷思。很多人害怕催眠会让他们睡着，但这几乎从未发生过，因为在某些文化中，那是一种尴尬的形式。大多数情况下，人们对周围发生的事情是清醒的，但在我们心理治疗中使用的一些深度复杂的催眠中，通常这就像是说你的大脑在
in a light sleep. So if when people are in this phase, they're not asleep, but they will, but if you tell them that I'm going to snap my fingers and you'll wake up, they'll respond to the suggestions. So they're integrating the suggestions, but there are periods of time where it's just that their brain goes into a type of twilight form of functioning. We talked a little bit about some of the problems that hypnosis can address. And I've read about hypnosis for smoking cessation, we mentioned anxiety, insomnia, other kinds of physical and mental health issues, are most of these backed by research, and where is the evidence the strongest? Most of these are indeed backed by research. I think some of the strongest research is in acute and chronic
浅睡眠中关闭了。所以当人们处于这个阶段时，他们不是在睡觉，但如果你告诉他们我打个响指你就会醒来，他们会对这些暗示做出反应。因此，他们正在整合这些暗示，但有时他们的脑功能只是进入了一种黄昏状态。我们讨论了一点催眠可以解决的问题。我读过关于用催眠来戒烟的资料，我们提到了焦虑、失眠以及其他身心健康问题，这些大部分都有研究支持吗？证据最强的是哪些？其中大部分确实有研究支持。我认为证据最强的一些领域是急性疼痛和慢性疼痛，
pain, and particularly my colleague, Mark Jensen, has done a number of randomized controlled trials on chronic pain. I did a lot on burn pain and surgeries. There is irritable bowel syndrome has a lot of literature now to support it. Reduction of anxiety. Smoking sensation and the name to look there is Joe Green. He's done a lot of work on it. There is some evidence that hypnosis helps with weight loss. not only helps with it, but people who use hypnosis, the weight loss lasts longer. So those are a few things. I do want to emphasize again that I think the best model to use hypnosis is to have someone in psychotherapy and then basically boost the effects of psychotherapy by using hypnosis at the right time.
尤其是我的同事马克·延森，他对慢性疼痛做了许多随机对照试验。我在烧伤疼痛和手术方面做了很多研究。肠易激综合征现在有大量文献支持。减少焦虑。戒烟方面可以关注乔·格林这个名字。他在这个领域做了大量工作。有一些证据表明催眠有助于减肥。不仅有助于减肥，而且使用催眠的人，减肥效果维持的时间更长。这些只是一小部分。我再次强调，我认为使用催眠的最佳模式是让患者接受心理治疗，然后在适当的时候通过使用催眠来增强心理治疗的效果。
So are some people, they just can't be hypnotized at all? I mean, there's like a range, right, of who can be hypnotized and who can't be hypnotized. Like, what does that curve look like? Is it a classic bell curve? Can you give us some idea of statistically, you know, how many, what's the percentage of the population that can be hypnotized and can't be hypnotized? Yeah. First of all, it is a bell-shaped curve, like you said. and there's maybe 10% of people that just don't seem to respond,
那么有些人是真的完全无法被催眠吗？我的意思是，比如存在一个范围，对吧，关于谁能被催眠，谁不能被催眠。那么，这条曲线是什么样子的？它是一个经典的钟形曲线吗？您能给我们大致讲讲统计数据吗，比如说，人口中有多少比例的人可以被催眠，多少比例的人无法被催眠？是的。首先，正如你所说，它是一个钟形曲线。大约有10%的人似乎没有反应，
and 10 to 15 people on the other tail that are very responsive. It is a bit skewed to what we would say, mild to moderate hypnotizable. And so probably the majority of people fall in that category. And just a quick note, the way we measure it, hypnotize abilities, you hypnotize someone, you give them a series of maybe 12 suggestions, and hypnotize ability is measured by how many suggestions they follow. And it's sort of a circular argument, you know, because it's really just saying how many suggestions they respond to rather than something more special than that. What can hypnosis not do? For example,
而另一端有10%到15%的人反应非常灵敏。它有点向我们所说的轻度到中度易被催眠人群倾斜。所以可能大多数人都属于这一类。顺便说一句，我们测量易被催眠度的方法是，你催眠某人，给他们一系列大概12个暗示，易被催眠度是通过他们遵循了多少个暗示来衡量的。这有点像循环论证，你知道的，因为它实际上只是在说明他们对多少个暗示有反应，而不是比这更特殊的东西。催眠不能做什么？例如，
could somebody who is highly suggestible be hypnotized into committing murder or doing something that they wouldn't do in their waking non-hypnotized life? Excellent question. And the first, the answer to committing murder and antisocial acts is no. There's been a number of studies that have demonstrated that. And as a matter of fact, the CIA, I believe this was in the 50s or 60s, followed the notion of the Manchurian man and try to hypnotize people to have them be hit men or hit women or whatever. And it never quite worked. But that so people won't do antisocial acts. And for the most part,
是否可以把一个高度易受暗示的人催眠去谋杀，或者去做他们在清醒、未被催眠的生活中不会做的事情？这是一个极好的问题。关于谋杀和反社会行为的答案是“不能”。许多研究已经证明了这一点。事实上，我相信是在50年代或60年代，中央情报局曾追随“满洲候选人”的概念，试图催眠人们让他们成为杀手或执行其他任务。但这从未真正成功过。所以人们不会去做反社会行为。而且在大多数情况下，
people won't do what they don't want to do. You know, there's the whole cluck like a chicken. But But most people won't do that unless they're willing to go with the show. Is there anyone who shouldn't try hypnosis because it could harm them more than help them? Yes. And I think I want to really refer to groups of people who have learned to use dissociation as a response to trauma early in her childhood, perhaps with sexual. abuse or other types of trauma. And they use it so often that it becomes part of their personalities. And these are people that can really dissociate with the drop of a hat.
人们不会做他们不想做的事情。你知道，就像那个模仿鸡咯咯叫的梗。但大多数人不会那样做，除非他们愿意配合演出。有没有什么人不应该尝试催眠，因为它带来的伤害可能大于帮助？有的。我想特别指出那些在童年早期由于遭受创伤（也许是性虐待或其他类型的创伤）而学会使用解离作为应对机制的人群。他们经常使用这种机制，以至于它成为了他们人格的一部分。这些人往往能在瞬间就发生解离。
And I wouldn't say that they should never use hypnosis. But when you're using hypnosis with people with really dissociate tendencies, you have to be very structured and not. for example, not regress them to early childhood, unless it's very well controlled, because that could bring up a lot of damaging material. What about self-hypnosis? There's always a lot of talk about how you can learn to do this yourself and you can perhaps control your weight or your smoking or other things. How well does that work and is it as effective as being hypnotized by a scientific practitioner like yourself? Well, first of all, what I see us doing with hypnosis is you're really
我并不是说他们绝对不能使用催眠。但当你对有真正解离倾向的人使用催眠时，你必须非常结构化，例如，除非控制得非常好，否则不要让他们退行到幼儿期，因为这可能会引发大量具有破坏性的材料。自我催眠呢？总是有很多人讨论你可以如何学习自己做这件事，从而可能控制你的体重、吸烟或其他问题。这效果如何？它和由像你这样的科学从业者进行催眠一样有效吗？嗯，首先，在我看来，我们用催眠所做的事情，实际上是在
tricking the logical part of the brain and you're getting people out of their, their cognitive automatic functioning. And there is, there's a way of capturing attention and several ways to do that. And so I think for the most part, it's always better for someone else to hypnotize me or a patient's going to have better luck if I'm hypnotizing them. Now, having said that, and this has really changed with smartphones, most of us clinical people and in our research too, we have the patients record the inductions on their phone and listen to them daily. and in our own research shows that that really strengthens the effects. And for an issue like chronic pain, you're not going to cure anyone in one session. Well, for that matter, you only manage chronic pain. You don't cure it.
欺骗大脑中负责逻辑的部分，让人们摆脱认知自动化的运作方式。而且确实有一种吸引注意力的方法，有几种方法可以做到这一点。所以我想在大多数情况下，由别人来催眠我总是更好，或者如果我催眠患者，患者会有更好的运气。话虽如此，随着智能手机的普及，这种情况真的改变了，我们大多数临床人员和我们的研究中，都会让患者在手机上录下诱导过程并每天收听，我们自己的研究表明这确实增强了效果。对于慢性疼痛这样的大问题，你不可能通过一次治疗就治愈任何人。好吧，话说回来，你只能控制慢性疼痛。你无法治愈它。
But to work with chronic pain, you want people to be practicing it every day. And they do indeed get better at it. So I guess I kind of have both answers to your question. It's better if other people hypnotize you, but you'll get better and better at it if you do self-hypnosis. Now, you do a lot of work with really acute pain, people who have been burned. First of all, how did you get into that? What made you decide at some point to give that a try to see if you could help a burn victim through hypnosis? I'm so glad you asked that question because there was one event that happened in,
但为了应对慢性疼痛，你需要人们每天练习。他们也确实在这方面变得越来越熟练。所以我想我对你的问题的回答是两方面的。别人催眠你会更好，但如果你进行自我催眠，你会变得越来越熟练。现在，你做了大量关于急性疼痛的工作，比如烧伤患者。首先，你是怎么开始接触这个领域的？是什么促使你在某个时刻决定尝试一下，看看能否通过催眠帮助烧伤患者？我很高兴你问了这个问题，因为在烧伤重症监护室发生的一件事
a burn ICU that really shifted my whole career. And I was hired as the psychologist for the University of Washington burn unit on a Department of Rehab Medicine. And when I showed up in early 80s, Bill Fordyce was on faculty then. And Bill was the grandfather of the psychology pain control, period. And I was lucky to overlap with him for a couple of years, and he was very gracious and provided me supervision. I would ask him all kinds of advice. And then the bird unit approached me and said, we need your help with burn debreedments. And I went to Bill and he said, I said, what do you suggest? And he said, have you tried hypnosis?
真正改变了我的整个职业生涯。我被聘为华盛顿大学烧伤科康复医学部的心理学家。当我8年代初报到时，比尔·福代斯当时是教员。比尔是心理疼痛控制领域的鼻祖。我很幸运能与他共事几年，他非常亲切并为我提供督导。我会向他寻求各种建议。后来烧伤科找到我，说我们需要你帮忙处理烧伤清创。我去找比尔，我说，你有什么建议？他说，你试过催眠吗？
And I was amazed that he said that being kind of an operant behavioral guy. So I found an induction that was published by a psychologist named Joseph Barber. I went up into the ICU. and I did this induction where I brought the patient down 20 steps, and then I touched him on the shoulder. And I said, when a nurse is touch you on the shoulder, you won't feel any pain and you'll be able to go very comfortably through your burn debrisments.
我很惊艳他会这么说，因为他是一个操作性行为主义者。所以我找到了一位名叫约瑟夫·巴伯的心理学家发表的诱导方法。我去了重症监护室，我做了这样一个诱导：我引导患者走下20级台阶，然后我拍拍他的肩膀。我说，当护士拍你的肩膀时，你将感觉不到任何疼痛，你将能够非常舒适地经历烧伤清创。
And then I brought them back up. Well, I said to myself, yeah, like, that's really going to work. Because I want to add that this patient was refusing. to go in wound cleaning, high doses of morphine, valium, nitrous oxide, and he said, I'm not going, just let me die. And that's no exaggeration. He went in there. So I showed up on the ward later that afternoon and everyone was so excited and said, what did you do to this guy? And I said, well, I used hypnosis. I said, why? They said, we touched him on the shoulder. He fell in asleep. He looked like he fell asleep. And we did all of his bird debreedment. And for the rest of his
然后我把他们带了回来。嗯，我对自己说，是的，这真的会管用。因为我想补充一下，这个患者当时拒绝去进行伤口清洗，大剂量的吗啡、安定、一氧化二氮都用上了，他说，我不去，让我死吧。这不是夸张。他进去了。所以我那天下午晚些时候出现在病房里，每个人都兴奋极了，说，你对这这家伙做了什么？我说，嗯，我用了催眠。我说，为什么？他们说，我们拍了拍他的肩膀。他睡着了。他看起来像睡着了。我们完成了他所有的烧伤清创，并且在余下的
hospitalization, they just touched him on the shoulder. He went limp and they would do his, did all his debreedment. And about a month later, after he was discharged, he came back to the outpatient clinic. And, you know, I didn't realize I was doing it. But I said, hey, Joe, how are you? And I touched him on the shoulder and he collapsed in my arms. Wow. So I've seldom got it to, work that well afterwards, but that led to me applying for NIH and getting my first grant in 1989, and that grant lasted for 30 years straight. So it was a really great relationship with NIH. That's an amazing story. Now, you combine hypnosis with some other techniques, right, when you're working with people. How does that work? Yes. After using hypnosis,
住院期间，他们只是碰了一下他的肩膀。他就四肢无力了，然后他们为他做了所有清创处理。大约在一个月后，他出院了，他回到了门诊。而且，你知道，我当时没有意识到自己在这样做。但我说，嘿，乔，你好吗？我碰了他的肩膀，他倒在了我的怀里。哇。所以此后我很少能让它发挥那么好的效果，但这促使我申请了美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）的资助，并在1989年获得了我的第一笔资助，这笔资助持续了整整30年。所以这与NIH建立了非常棒的关系。这真是一个了不起的故事。现在，当你和人们合作时，你将催眠与其他一些技术结合起来，对吧？那是怎么运作的？是的。在使用催眠之后，
for maybe 10 or 15 years, I meant my colleague named Hunter Hoffman, and he designed an immersive virtual world for people going through burn care. And we would put people in three-dimensional worlds, and it was called Snow World, is still out there. And so they would be engrossed in this cool world during the burn care, and they wouldn't be able to see what was going on. So we did that for a number of years. And then I did some work to try to combine immersive virtual reality with hypnosis as a vehicle to deliver it. And so far that hasn't worked particularly well. Immersive virtual reality works great by itself. Hypnosis works great by itself.
大约10或15年后，我遇到了我的同事亨特·霍夫曼（Hunter Hoffman），他为接受烧伤护理的人设计了一个沉浸式虚拟世界。我们会把人们置于三维世界中，这个世界被称为“冰雪世界”（Snow World），现在依然存在。因此，在烧伤护理期间，他们会全神贯注于这个酷炫的世界，而看不到正在发生的事情。所以我们做了好几年。然后我做了一些工作，试图将沉浸式虚拟现实与催眠结合起来，作为传递催眠的载体。到目前为止，这种效果并不是特别好。沉浸式虚拟现实本身效果很好。催眠本身效果也很好。
But I haven't been able to design a sophisticated enough type of technology to deliver hypnosis through VR. And indeed, they're two separate processes, you know, and we've published in journal of abnormal psychology on how you have these, there's two separate processes going on when we compare them empirically. Now, is hypnosis taught as a matter of course in graduate psychology programs? Less and less. I think, I don't want this to sound the wrong way, but I think, think hypnosis has been hijacked by mindfulness. And I feel very comfortable saying that because much of my work is around mindfulness now and with my patients. And then I work hard to combine hypnosis with mindfulness. But hypnosis has had a waxing and waning history since the
但我还没能设计出足够复杂的科技，通过VR来传递催眠。事实上，它们是两个独立的过程，你知道的，我们已经在《异常心理学期刊》（Journal of Abnormal Psychology）上发表过文章，探讨了当我们对它们进行实证比较时，这两个独立的过程是如何进行的。那么，在研究生心理学课程中，催眠是否作为一门常规课程教授？越来越少了。我想，我不想让这话听起来不对劲，但我认为，催眠已经被正念劫持了。我觉得说这话我很坦然，因为我的很多工作现在都围绕着正念以及我的患者展开。然后我努力将催眠与正念结合起来。但自19世纪以来，
1800s. And one of the reasons it kind of left the stage, was the advent of ether. And it was a lot more efficient to use ether with patients. And then it would come back, it would make a comeback. And then when mindfulness just really overtook graduate schools, they became a lot less interest in hypnosis. But with a lot of the brain studies and so on, I do think it's making another surge.
催眠经历了一段起起落落的历史。它淡出历史舞台的原因之一是乙醚的出现。对患者使用乙醚要高效得多。然后它又卷土重来，东山再起。后来，当正念真正风靡研究生院时，他们对催眠的兴趣就大大减弱了。但随着许多大脑研究等等的开展，我确实认为它正在迎来又一次激增。
So if our listeners, for example, are interested in finding a therapist who can help them, maybe with a combination of hypnotherapy and cognitive behavioral therapy or something because they've got a problem that could be addressed by this. How should they go about finding a practitioner who's qualified to do this? Well, your question brings up one of the important issues that I talk about is I don't think hypnosis is owned by psychologists or health professionals. I mean, we can't lay claim to it. There is a whole guild of hypnotherapists that aren't trained in any type of health care.
所以，如果我们的听众，例如，有兴趣寻找能够帮助他们的治疗师，也许是通过催眠治疗和认知行为疗法相结合的方式，或者因为他们有一些可以通过这种方式解决的问题。他们应该如何去寻找具备相应资格的从业者呢？嗯，你的问题提出了我所讨论的重要问题之一，那就是我认为催眠不属于心理学家或健康专业人员。我的意思是，我们不能声称对其拥有所有权。有一个庞大的催眠治疗师行会，他们没有接受过任何类型的医疗保健培训。
They're just trained in hypnosis. And, you know, I think that they can hypnotize people and, you know, do things like enhance creativity, things like that. But I think if someone has a health issue, particularly any type of, significant mental illness, things like pain. I think it's best to go to a good psychologist who has hypnosis as part of their treatment package. So in other words, a good psychologist is going to look at a half dozen types of intervention. And then based on a patient or based on when we're in therapy, we enter in hypnosis. a hypnotherapist uses hypnosis as a hammer to hit every nail.
他们只接受过催眠培训。而且，你知道，我认为他们可以催眠人们，并且，你知道，做一些增强创造力之类的事情。但我认为，如果某人有健康问题，尤其是任何类型的严重精神疾病、疼痛之类的问题。我认为最好去找一位将催眠作为其治疗方案一部分的优秀心理学家。换句话说，一个优秀的心理学家会考虑半打左右的干预类型。然后根据患者的情况，或者根据我们在治疗时的状态，我们进入催眠状态。催眠治疗师则把催眠当作锤子去敲击每一颗钉子。
So I discourage, you know, people away from that. The American Society of Clinical Hypnosis does a lot of training and has a list of practitioners. There's a society for experimental and clinical hypnosis who also does, and they also do a lot of training. but I do have to admit that it's difficult to find a psychologist that does hypnosis. Again, it's part of the waning period that we have. And I think there is going to be more and more of them that are trained as good therapists and in hypnosis as well. But it sounds like from what you told the story about how you started using hypnosis
所以我劝阻人们不要那样做。美国临床催眠学会（American Society of Clinical Hypnosis）做了大量的培训，并有一份从业者名单。实验与临床催眠学会（Society for Experimental and Clinical Hypnosis）也这样做，他们也进行了大量的培训。但我必须承认，很难找到一个做催眠的心理学家。再次强调，这是我们所处的衰退期的一部分。我认为会有越来越多的受过良好治疗师培训以及催眠培训的人出现。但听了你讲述的你是如何开始对烧伤患者使用催眠的故事，
with a burn victim and that you read a paper and that you hypnotized him. I mean, was that described in the paper? So how did you really know how to do this? I mean, how do you hypnotize a person? Where do you learn this? I had a fair amount of that in my graduate school. I had it in internship and post-doctoral training. And so I did, you know, and I think a really,
以及你读了一篇论文然后催眠了他。我的意思是，那篇论文里是这么描述的吗？所以你怎么真正知道如何做到这一点呢？我的意思是，你如何催眠一个人？你在哪里学到这个的？我在研究生院学过相当一部分这方面的知识。我在实习和博士后培训中也接触过。所以我确实，你知道的，而且我认为一个非常，
really good example is most psychologists are trained in progressive relaxation, right? And progressive relaxation really is the foundation of hypnosis. You know, you're, you're counting them downstairs, and you're scanning the body and relaxing them. So I had had had a lot of training in that biofeedback. And it's a, I mean, any good graduate training is going to provide the platform. What But what the adduction I read is it really targeted a post-hypnotic suggestion for a medical procedure. And I think this is one of the strongest uses of hypnosis that there is, is that if someone's going through surgery, childbirth, burn care, dentistry, you can work with them when
非常好的例子是，大多数心理学家都接受过渐进式放松训练，对吧？渐进式放松实际上是催眠的基础。你知道的，你在让他们数着台阶往下走，你在扫描他们的身体并让他们放松。所以我在这方面和生物反馈方面接受过大量的培训。而且，任何优秀的研究生培训都会提供这个平台。但是，我读到的导引词真正针对的是医疗程序的催眠后暗示。我认为这是催眠最强大的用途之一，那就是如果某人要经历手术、分娩、烧伤护理、牙科治疗，你可以在他们
they're calm. They're not on a lot of medication. You can hypnotize them. You can make a tape. but then it all comes down to this post-hypnotic suggestion that when they're walking in for their surgery or when they feel that IV line going in, that's the cue. That's the stimulus for them to go into a deep, relaxed state. And it's, so it's classical conditioning at its very core, but hypnosis, one of the things with hypnosis is it would drive me nuts to sit there for, for 30 minutes to do progressive relaxation.
平静的时候与他们合作。他们没有服用大量药物。你可以催眠他们。你可以制作一盘磁带。但这最终都归结于这个催眠后暗示：当他们走进手术室或者感觉到静脉注射管扎进去时，这就是线索。这就是让他们进入深度放松状态的刺激。所以这可以说是核心的经典条件反射，但是催眠，催眠的一大特点是，如果让我坐在那里花30分钟做渐进式放松，我会疯掉的。
The brain, when someone's hypnotized, it's like you can do a 20-minute progressive relaxation in five minutes. And I just love that. The brain functions differently, and it's much more efficiently, and there definitely are changes in the way people process information
当一个人处于催眠状态时，大脑的运作方式就像你可以在五分钟内完成20分钟的渐进式放松一样。我非常喜欢这一点。大脑的功能不同了，而且效率高得多，而且当人们处于催眠状态时，他们处理信息的方式确实发生了变化。
when they're under hypnosis. Now, since the pandemic, a lot of therapy has moved online. Is it possible to do hypnosis remotely? Absolutely. When I, when the pandemic came along, you know, I'm in an area of rehabilitation, psychology, and disabilities, and we've been screaming for remote treatment for years for people that can't get into the office. And then all of a sudden, the pandemic comes along, and in two weeks, were set up with this whole platform. So I was seeing all of my patients through Zoom,
现在，自从大流行以来，许多治疗都转移到了线上。远程进行催眠可能吗？绝对可以。当大流行来临时，你知道，我从事康复心理学和残疾领域的工作，多年来我们一直在为那些无法去办公室的人呼吁远程治疗。然后突然之间，大流行来了，在两周内，我们就建立好了这个整个平台。所以我通过Zoom接待我所有的患者，
and 90% of the hypnosis I did was over Zoom. And again, what I would do is have the patients have their phone and record the session. But Zoom's nice because it's not nearly as good as live hypnosis, but at least you can see, you know, see your patient. And when you're with the patient and you're hypnotizing them, the ultimate scenario is that you're really in tune with their body. They're breathing.
而且我90%的催眠都是通过Zoom完成的。再说一次，我会做的是让患者拿着手机并录制疗程。但Zoom很好，因为它虽然不如现场催眠那么好，但至少你能看到，你知道的，看到你的患者。当你和患者在一起并催眠他们时，最终的场景是你真正与他们的身体保持同频。他们在呼吸。
And you're breathing with them. And you notice that someone does, you know, just puts their head back and you reinforce that. So there's a real advantage to being able to see the person, much better in person than in Zoom, but Zoom works. So I have to ask you another question related to some of these stage hypnotists. Many, many years ago I went to one of these sessions where a hypnotist was going to help people go through past life regression. And in this demonstration, this person would hypnotize somebody who would then go back to what was supposed to be a prior life.
你和他们一起呼吸。你注意到有人，你知道的，只是把头靠向后方，你强化了这一点。所以能看到这个人有着真正的优势，面对面比在Zoom上好得多，但Zoom确实管用。所以我不得不问你另一个与这些舞台催眠师有关的问题。很多很多年前，我去参加过这样的一次活动，当时一个催眠师要帮助人们进行前世回归。在这个示范中，这个人会催眠某人，然后这个人会回到据称是前世的时期。
is this just quackery? I mean, what is going on when that happens? And somebody comes along and says, well, I'm in the forest. I know I'm a Navajo Indian. I know, I mean, they start just telling you a whole story about who they are and where they came from. What is happening with these people? Well, first of all, one of the best researchers that I've ever met is Mike Nash and that a University of Tennessee. and someone ran that question by me, he said, past life regression is fine if you're looking at things from the standpoint of religion, right? That's a religious phenomenon.
这只是庸医骗术吗？我的意思是，当这种情况发生时，到底发生了什么？有人走过来，说，我在森林里。我知道我是一个纳瓦霍印第安人。我知道，我的意思是，他们开始讲述一个关于他们是谁以及他们来自哪里的完整故事。这些人的身上发生了什么？嗯，首先，我见过的最优秀的 дослід者（研究人员）之一是迈克·纳什（Mike Nash），他在田纳西大学。有人拿这个问题问过我，他说，如果你从宗教的角度来看待事物，前世回归是没问题的，对吧？那是一种宗教现象。
Now, with, if you hit, one of the things that really happens with hypnosis is that people have very vivid imagery. Remember, the brain kind of shifts over, and so things can become very real. And that's why there was a huge, one of the most embarrassing periods of psychology is when people were planting suggestions for early trauma through hypnosis and not letting the patient arrive to him, but planning those.
现在，如果你催眠……催眠真正发生的事情之一是，人们会有非常生动的意象。记住，大脑有点发生了转变，所以事情可以变得非常真实。这就是为什么曾有过一个巨大的、心理学最尴尬的时期之一——当时人们通过催眠将早期创伤的暗示植入患者心中，不是让患者自己去发现，而是植入这些暗示。
And hypnosis can make a false memory appear very real, okay? It reminds me of Mike Nash had a patient that was reported he was abducted by aliens. So he took him in hypnosis and they went through the whole abduction and came back. And he didn't really question it, but he used it as a symbolic thing for psychoanalytically. And a patient got a lot better, but he didn't really question whether the abduction was real or not. Similarly, when you hypnotize, if you give suggestions for past life regression with hypnosis, people, as you said, can have very vivid images. Now, I think it's very interesting that everyone seems to go back to the 17th century
催眠可以让虚假的记忆显得非常真实，好吗？这让我想起迈克·纳什曾有一个患者报告说自己被外星人劫持了。于是他在催眠状态下带患者经历了整个劫持过程并回溯。他并没有真正质疑这一点，而是把它当作精神分析学上的一个象征性事物来使用。患者的情况好了很多，但他并没有真正去质疑劫持是真是假。同样地，当你催眠时，如果你给出前世回归的暗示，正如你所说，人们可以拥有非常生动的意象。现在，我觉得非常有趣的是，每个人似乎都会回到17世纪
and be run over by a carriage. Okay. So my question, the way I say, the way I see regression to past lives, if you hypnotize me, how far back am I going to go in human evolution? And I often say that if you hypnotize me, I'd probably go back to a newt, you know, and just I would just be this wiggling thing because that's one of the things. Like when you really look at science and evolution, it's like, you know, we didn't start in the 17th century or any time close to that.
然后被马车撞倒。好的。所以我的问题是，在我看来，回溯到前世的方式是，如果你催眠我，我在人类进化史上能追溯到多远？我经常说，如果你催眠了我，我可能会变成一只蝾螈，你知道的，我只会变成一个扭动的东西，因为那是事情的一部分。就像当你真正审视科学和进化时，你会发现，你知道的，我们并不是从17世纪或任何接近这个时间的时期开始的。
I'm remembering the primordial slime, yes. Exactly. Exactly. But it is possible to take people back in their own lives, right? And that's legitimate. I mean, those are things that can be checked, right? Exactly. Exactly.
我记起了原始黏液，是的。没错。没错。但是把人们带回他们自己的生活中是可能的，对吧？那是合法的。我的意思是，那些是可以核实的事情，对吧？没错。没错。
And, you know, it's one of the techniques, one of the really powerful techniques of hypnosis is that if someone's in pain or they're depressed, you can take them back earlier in life. to happier times. And you can really have them integrate those resources. And then you bring them back to the present, and they still have this really positive affect. I wanted to mention, speaking of past life regression, when I was in graduate school, I read a paper in Journal of Abnormal Psychology that fascinated me. and the study is they took adults and they gave them a computer task that you need idetic imagery to do.
而且，你知道，这是催眠的技巧之一，是一个非常强大的催眠技巧，如果有人处于痛苦中或抑郁，你可以把他们带回早年生活中更快乐的时光。你可以真正让他们整合这些资源。然后你把他们带回现在，他们仍然有这种非常积极的情感。我想提一下，说到前世回归，当我在研究生院时，我读了一篇发表在《异常心理学期刊》上的论文，它深深地迷住了我。这项研究是他们找来成年人，给他们一个需要靠 eidetic imagery（ eidetic 意象/摄影式记忆）才能完成的计算机任务。
And there's a theory that we all have idetic imagery before language as children. I don't know how accurate that is. But they regressed these adults to children and they were able to do the task more. And that was, I think, one of the reasons I really got. interested in hypnosis. And so I don't know if it was replicated, but I think just the concept was so creative and fascinating. But yes, you can definitely regress people. When you're regressing them, you have to be really careful. If you just let them go anywhere, you can bring up some really damaging material that people can't really deal with. So when I'm using it clinically,
有一个理论认为，我们在儿童时期掌握语言之前都拥有 eidetic 意象。我不知道这有多准确。但他们将这些成年人回退到儿童时期，他们能够更好地完成这项任务。我认为这是我真正对催眠产生兴趣的原因之一。所以，我不知道它是否被复制了，但我认为这个概念本身就非常有创意且迷人。但是是的，你绝对可以让人回溯。当你在让他们回溯时，你必须非常小心。如果你只是让他们去任何地方，你可能会唤起一些真正具有破坏性的材料，而人们实际上无法应对。所以当我在临床上使用它时，
I say find yourself going back to early images and time as long as the positive images and as long as you feel safe. So yes, I hope that answers that. You know, some of this sounds very similar to some of the psychedelic therapy that's happening right now. Like a year and a half ago or something like that, I talked to somebody who's doing that kind of therapy. And it's the same sort of thing that you need somebody guiding you through it, that you don't want to take people places that might be dangerous. Is there something similar? Do you think that's happening with people who might be doing psychedelic therapy and doing hypnotherapy? Absolutely. I have to respond somewhat personally. I lost a son over last year and I decided, I'd been referring some of my terminal patients
我说，只要是积极的意象，只要你感到安全，就找到自己回到早期的意象和时间的方式。所以，是的，我希望这回答了那个问题。你知道，其中一些听起来与现在正在进行的一些迷幻治疗非常相似。比如一年半前左右，我和一个正在做这种治疗的人交流过。这和你的情况差不多，你需要有人引导你度过难关，你不想把人们带到可能有危险的地方。有什么相似之处吗？你认为那些可能在做迷幻治疗和催眠治疗的人身上正在发生这种情况吗？绝对是的。我必须做出一些个人的回应。我在去年失去了儿子，我决定——我一直在把一些晚期患者转诊
to psychedelic therapy, but I decided to pursue it myself in Denver with two top-notch therapists. and I did a psilocybin trip, again, with the two therapists, but I was amazed at how much similarity there is to the way I do advanced hypnosis. And when the guide was introducing what was going to happen, it sounded very much like advanced hypnosis. And it ended up being very useful for me. So last question. I like to ask this often with people who are,
到迷幻治疗，但我决定亲自在丹佛由两位顶尖的治疗师陪同尝试一下。我进行了一次赛洛西宾（迷幻蘑菇）之旅，同样是由两位治疗师陪同，但我惊奇地发现，它与我进行高级催眠的方式有如此多的相似之处。当引导者介绍将要发生的事情时，听起来非常像高级催眠。最后证明这对我也非常有用。所以最后一个问题。我经常向那些在实地从事有趣工作的人问这个问题。你现在在做什么？你想解答的重大问题是什么？我现在正在做的事情是，我正在撰写我的APA（美国心理学会）书籍的第二版，但真正的重点是，我对心灵运作方式的神经生理学非常感兴趣，以及这样一种观点：基本上，当我们实际上没有“自我”时，我们在思考，我们只能谈论我们的“自我”不是什么。但我们认为的“自我”永远是一个瞬时的过程，非常具有禅宗的意味。但我认为我们陷入麻烦的很大一部分原因是通过关注过去和未来，这两者都是心灵的幻觉。所以我经常教患者如何冥想，然后我用催眠来，再次强调，我认为催眠最大的用处只是，
doing interesting work out there in the field. What are you working on now? What are the big questions you'd like to answer? What I'm working on now, I'm working on a second edition of my APA book, but the real focus is I'm very interested in the neurophysiology of the way the mind works and the notion that basically we think when we don't really have a self, we can only talk about what ourselves are not. But what we think is ourself is always a transient process, very zen-like type of thing. But a lot of the way I think we get into trouble is by focusing on the past and the future, which are both the illusions of the mind. So I very often teach patients how to meditate, but then I use hypnosis to, again, I think the greatest use of hypnosis is just,
加速心理治疗，这是不同的学习过程，但要有一个良好的基础。所以我现在特别感兴趣的是，某种程度上以一种佛教对心灵的理解——将其视为一个过程而不是一个固定实体，摆脱二元论的思维，并通过科学来解释它，然后通过催眠来增强它。这听起来太棒了。我期待着在你编写下一版书籍时看到这些成果。我要感谢帕特森博士今天加入我的节目。和你聊天真的非常有趣。谢谢你，金。你可以在我们的网站 www.Speakingof Psychology.org 或者在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《Speaking of Psychology》节目。如果你喜欢我们所听到的内容，请给我们留下评价。我们也想更多地了解你对这个播客的看法以及你希望我们提供更多什么内容。我们也想了解你。
to accelerate psychotherapy, different learning process, but to have a good foundation. So I'm particularly interested in now as somewhat of a Buddhist understanding of the mind as process rather than a fixed entity and getting away from dualistic thinking and explain that through science and then augment it through hypnosis. That sounds amazing. I look forward to seeing this as you work on the next edition of your books. I want to thank you. Dr. Patterson for joining me today. It's been really a lot of fun talking to you. Thank you, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.Speakingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. We'd also like to learn more about what you think of this podcast and what you'd like to hear more of from us. We'd like to know about you as well.
所以如果可以的话，你能访问我们的网站 www.speakingof psychology.org 并寻找指向我们听众调查的链接吗？我们将不胜感激。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《Speaking of Psychology》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。这期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
So if you could, would you go to our website, www. speakingof psychology.org and look for a link to our listener's survey. We'd really appreciate it. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您可以的话，请访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org，并找到指向我们听众调查的链接。我们将不胜感激。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学话题》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音响剪辑师是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。